[Música]
hola buenos días feliz de estar aquí
compartiendo con ustedes esta mañana y
la verdad que he dicho eso es cuando yo
estaba en el cole este tipo de eventos
no existían y no nos traían además
entonces cada uno que estaba aquí
sentado me imagino que han ido viendo
todas estas exposiciones se han ido
pensando mentalmente que me llevo de
cada una de ellas bueno para comenzar
estamos aquí el tema es nuestro futuro
en ruedas
yo nací crecí y vivo en una familia
donde los motores la gasolina los carros
durval y la velocidad es es parte de mi
vida el día de mi boda mi papá en el
discurso dijo que nuestra familia no
copiada sangre sino gasolina
adicionalmente me casé con un conocedor
y restaurador de carlos clásicos que es
el más apasionado de todos en la casa
y el índice y mover con esta trayectoria
familiar ha logrado evolucionar para
poder impactar a los jóvenes en una
formación técnica si hubieran preguntado
cuando tenía la edad de ustedes acá no
sé 16 18 años que que si me veía cuando
fuera grande dirigiendo un instituto
técnico enfocado en la mecánica tal vez
hubiera dicho como uy qué miedo no sé es
demasiada responsabilidad pero bueno hoy
estoy acá y lo que he aprendido es que
todo este entorno que nos rodea y de
dónde venimos y nuestros
hay que sacarle provecho para realmente
hacer algo positivo al respecto
no sé si hay algunos curiosos acá y
seguro cuando se montan todas las
mañanas en la moto en el bus para ir al
alcohol han dicho quién habrá sido el
maravilloso genio que inventó el carro
pues la respuesta es que en 1886 este
carro de tres ruedas fue inventado en
alemania por kyle wiens si el apellido
les suena es porque es uno de los
cofundadores de mercedes benz y él hizo
el primer carro de combustión interna
que caminaba a 16 kilómetros por hora y
él quería comprobar que era un método de
transporte super seguro y sencillo para
todo el mundo el primer viaje del mundo
lo hizo su esposa junto con sus dos
hijos en un trayecto de 96 kilómetros
comprobando que el carro era para todo
el mundo para mí lo personal me parece
increíble que la primer mujer perdón que
el primer carro fuera manejado por una
mujer y lo segundo del lindísimo ver
como esta trayectoria hoy en día es lo
que es mercedes benz
y algo que fue lindísimo es que de
casualidad en agosto de este año estuve
en un evento junto con mi esposo donde
vimos este capítulo chiquitito que es el
motor vago en el primer cargo del mundo
que se inventó en prefecto estaba
restauración y hoy en día es parte de la
unesco
en la industria automotriz ha impactado
y ha revolucionado a la industria el es
henry ford él fue la persona que inventó
la línea de producción en serie es el
fundador de ford motor company y la él
quería que el vehículo fuera algo
accesible para todo el mundo y no solo
para los estratos altos
él creó la línea de producción que hoy
en día los las empresas siguen
utilizando este modelo de línea de
producción este fue el modelo t el carro
que se hizo famoso y fue masificado
literalmente entre carl benz y henry
ford hicieron que el mundo empezara a
rodar en ruedas valga la redundancia
bueno plantas de hoy en día a ferrari
etcétera obviamente siguen con este
mismo principio de línea producción en
serie con un montón de mejoras pero algo
que tenemos que pensar y a veces uno no
le da la importancia al caso es de dónde
venimos cuál es ese origen cómo
comenzaron las cosas en el caso personal
nuestro también lo tenemos que pensar es
a dónde estoy parado ahorita que quiero
hacer toda esa energía y esas ruedas y
por eso es nuestra charla de hoy nuestro
futuro en ruedas es hacia donde nos
queremos dirigir y todo esto es continuo
aprendizaje continuo
porque estamos hoy acá tal vez les
cuento
la relación de nuestra empresa familiar
con más de 65 años en el país con una
trayectoria en temas enfocados a la
industria automotriz decidimos
implementar un proyecto más social y
hace 7 años creamos un instituto técnico
donde damos mecánica de vehículos
livianos mecánica motocicletas soldadura
carreras técnicas que también eso lo
hemos evolucionado a otro tipo no solo
de especialidades en mecánica sino en
generalidades técnicas y hemos querido
decir como todos estos 65 años los
podemos implementar para realmente
transmitirlo a la población joven y que
el aprendizaje técnico sea una
oportunidad para más personas también
somos fieles creyentes que las alianzas
público-privadas funcionan
trabajamos muy de la mano con el inah
dando un producto de calidad para todas
las personas que pasan por nuestro
instituto que es una educación técnica
muchas veces
no conocemos bien el concepto la
educación técnica hay carreras que se
inician desde los 15 años de edad no hay
un máximo de edad es económicamente
viable el bachillerato en algunos casos
es necesario en otros es opcional por lo
cual las personas que realmente quieren
y tienen la voluntad de aprender lo
pueden hacer eso es depende de cada uno
de nosotros un gran ejemplo que tenemos
actualmente es don gabriel él estudia
mecánica de vehículos los días sábados
él tiene 74 años nunca se me olvida el
que vino matricularle fue el hijo de él
un señor para que la redundancia y dijo
que el papá era súper activo y el señor
lleva dos años y ocho meses viniendo
todos los días todos los sábados él se
despierta a las tres de la mañana porque
ellos viven en puntarenas en carrizal y
esto es un claro ejemplo de aprendizaje
permanente el en diciembre si dios
quiere se gradúa y es una belleza
compartir verdad nosotros tenemos
personas desde los 15 años y un gran
ejemplo
y algo que es siempre vital importante
es depende de ustedes si son o no
exitosos están las oportunidades hay que
aprovecharlos y no limitarnos y él es un
gran ejemplo con 74 años seguirá activo
y más cuando lo vemos en el taller con
los muchachos interactuando todo el
aprendizaje que nos deja el lindísimo
algo que es importante
un 50 a 60 por ciento de lo que ustedes
van a aprender muchachos y muchachas es
lo que le enseñan a uno sea en el cole
en la ugl en los institutos es toda esa
parte profesional o técnica y el otro
gran mundo porque lo hemos visto es
todas esto que hoy muchos de todos los
conferencistas lo han hablado de las
famosas habilidades blandas que cada día
más bien son más habilidades
estratégicas en la inteligencia
emocional que cada uno de nosotros
tenemos y no sé si ustedes mismos
piensan por un segundo cuál es mi
potencial cuál es esa habilidad mía que
yo puedo desarrollar y que me va a ser
único en mi ambiente de trabajo un
clarísimo ejemplo es tenemos un mecánico
excelente buenísimo el día de las
carreras él tiene que trabajar en equipo
verdad ellos están ahí en la guásima
nosotros participamos en eventos súper
lindos en ahí en los pits tienen nada
verdad son literalmente segundos para
cambiar las llantas esto qué es eso es
un gran ejemplo y una gran muestra de
poder saber
con completar una tarea que le asignan
llevar las directrices a cabo trabajar
en equipo la puntualidad que hoy en día
en los millennials a veces cuesta un
poquitito esos son habilidades blandas
que la empresa las valora increíblemente
y a veces nada más decimos no eso es
súper fácil pero no lo desarrollamos en
el día a día
algo que quiero que se lleven tal vez de
la charla de hoy es que el tiempo no se
devuelve las oportunidades hay que
aprovecharlas y si no hay una
oportunidad tratar de hacer una
oportunidad de algo al respecto porque
el tiempo no se devuelve cuando uno es
joven a veces no mañana ha pasado como
lo dijeron en otra de las charlas día 1
la oportunidad no se devuelve y el
tiempo - yo me siento muy honrada y muy
feliz de ser una herramienta y una
puerta para todos los jóvenes que pasan
por nuestro instituto para poder darles
esa oportunidad de una inserción laboral
de la mano soy fiel creyente que la
educación técnico-profesional es el
futuro para todas las personas que
tienen esas destrezas y esas habilidades
que quieren poder hacer un cambio en sus
vidas y recuérdese en el futuro eso es
estar siempre en ruedas moviéndose el
futuro depende de cada uno de ustedes
y también que siempre lo mejor está por
venir así que muchos éxitos y muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]